>>> THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT I
ASKING A FEDERAL AEALS COURT
TO LET THE FBI REGAIN ACCESS TO
ABOUT 100 CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
THAT WERE TAKEN FROM DONALD
TRUMP'S MAR-A-LAGO ESTATE.
IT'S THE LATEST TURN IN THE
LEGAL FIGHT OVER THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S HANDLING OF
GOVERNMENT RECORDS.
MORE NOW FROM JESSICA SCHNEIDER.
>> Reporter: THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FILING THEIR APPEAL
WITH THE 11th CIRCUIT.
THEY'RE REALLY, THOUGH, ASKING
FOR LIMITED RELIEF.
THEY'RE TELLING THE COURT THAT
WHAT THEY WANT IS JUST TWO
THINGS THAT JUDGE AILEEN CANNON
REFUSED TO GIVE THEM WHEN THEY
RULED.
FIRST, THEY WANT TO BE ALLOWED
TO CONTINUE THEIR CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INTO CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS UNIMPEDED, MEANING
THEY WANT TO RESUME USING THOSE
100 CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN
THEIR PROBE THAT JUDGE CANNON
HAS SAID THEY CAN NO LONGER USE.
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO USE THEM
IN GRAND JURY PROCEEDINGS OR
WITH WITNESSES.
AND THEN THE SECOND THING
THEY'RE ASKING FOR IS DOJ IS
SAYING THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
TURN OVER THOSE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS TO TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM
OR THE SPECIAL MASTER IN THIS
CASE WHO'S BEEN APPOINTED.
THEY'RE SAYING THAT THE LOWER
COURT JUDGE HERE WAS JUST WRONG
TO ORDER THEM TO HAND OVER THIS
HIGHLY SENSITIVE MATERIAL ALL IN
THE MIDST OF THEIR ONGOING
INVESTIGATION.
AND THEN IN A BROADER SCALE
HERE, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
ARGUING THAT COURTS REALLY
SHOULDN'T EVEN BE STEPPING IN
HERE BECAUSE ALL THE DOCUMENTS
AT ISSUE BELONG TO THE
GOVERNMENT.
THEY PUT IT THIS WAY -- ALLOWING
THE GOVERNMENT TO USE AND REVIEW
THE RECORDS BEARING
CLASSIFICATION MARKINGS FOR
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIVE PURPOSES
WOULD NOT CAUSE ANY RECOGNIZABLE
INJURY TO PLAINTIFF.
AND THEN THEY WENT ON TO SAY
THAT IS WHY COURTS HAVE
EXERCISED GREAT CAUTION BEFORE
INTERFERING THROUGH CIVIL
ACTIONS WITH CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS OR CASES.
AND IN THAT LAST SENTENCE, THE
DOJ REALLY CRITICIZING THE LOWER
COURT JUDGE FOR EVEN STEPPING IN
HERE.
WE'LL SEE JUST HOW QUICKLY THE
11th CIRCUIT ACTS.
THIS IS ALL COMING AS THE
SPECIAL MASTER REVIEW OF THESE
DOCUMENTS IS JUST BEGINNING.
JUDGE RAYMOND DEARIE WHO'S BEEN
NAMED THE SPECIAL MASTER, HE HAS
SCHEDULED A HEARING FOR TUESDAY
AT 2:00 P.M. TO GO OVER HOW THE
SCHEDULING WILL WORK SINCE OF
COURSE THE CLOCK IS ALREADY
TICKING.
THE SPECIAL MASTER HAS TO REVIEW
11,000 OF THESE DOCUMENTS BY
NOVEMBER 30th.
JIM?
>> AND OUR THANKS TO JESSICA FOR
THAT.
AND SENIOR LEGAL ANALYST AND
FORMER PROSECUTOR ELLIE HOENIG
JOINS US NOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, HOW DO YOU
SEE THIS APPEAL PROCESS PLAYING
OUT?
COULD IT GO TO THE SUPREME
COURT?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> IT COULD, JIM.
THIS IS A VERY NARROW AND
STRATEGIC APPEAL BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
THEY'RE NOT APPEALING THE ENTIRE
SPECIAL MASTER ORDER, AS JESSICA
SAID.
THEY'RE SORT OF PLAYING THEIR
STRONGEST HAND HERE, THEY'RE
FOCUSING ONLY ON THOSE 100
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
DOJ'S ARGUMENT ESSENTIALLY IS
THERE CANNOT BE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE APPLICABLE TO THOSE
100 CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS, AND
THE SPECIAL MASTER SHOULD NOT
REVIEW THEM.
DONALD TRUMP'S RESPONSE HAS BEEN
HOW DO WE KNOW, WHY NOT HAVE A
THIRD PARTY COME IN AND TAKE A
LOOK AND LET'S MAKE SURE.
NOW THE NEXT STEP HERE IS THE
11th CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS.
THAT IS A CONSERVATIVE-LEANING
COURT.
SEVEN OF THE 11 ACTIVE JUDGES ON
THAT COURT ARE REPUBLICAN
NOMINEE TH -- NOMINEES, SIX ARE
DONALD TRUMP'S.
YOU'LL GET THROUGH JUDGES PICKED
AT RANDOM TO HEAR THIS.
THE LOSING SIDE CAN USE THE
REVIEW THAT MEANS ALL 11 JUDGES
HEAR IT.
THAT'S UP TO THE CIRCUIT.
IF THAT HAPPENS, IT'S GOING TO
BE 7-4 IN FAVOR OF REPUBLICAN
NOMINEES AND THEN WHOEVER LOSES
THERE CAN TRY TO GET IT UP TO
THE SUPREME COURT.
OF COURSE THE SUPREME COURT
DOESN'T HAVE TO TAKE ANY CASE.
IT WILL BE UP TO THEM.
THIS IS REALLY JUST THE START OF
WHAT COULD BE A LONG APPELLATE
JOURNEY.
I THINK IT'S A FAIRLY EVEN
CHANCE AS TO WHAT HAPPENS AT THE
NEXT STEP.
EITHER SIDE IS GOING TO HAVE
FURTHER REP D.C.
>> AND CNN HAS CONFIRMED THAT
TRUMP'S FORMER WHITE HOUSE
DEPUTY COUNSEL, PAT PHILBIN,
TOLD THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES BOXES
OF RECORDS WERE NEWSPAPER
CLIPPINGS.
PHILBIN SAYS THAT'S WHAT HE WAS
TOLD BY MARK MEADOWS.
NOW A MEADOWS SPOKESPERSON
SAYING THIS, MR. MEADOWS DID NOT
PERSONALLY REVIEW THE BOXES AT
MAR-A-LAGO, DID NOT HAVE A ROLE
IN EXAMINING OR VERIFYING WHAT
WAS OR WASN'T CONTAINED WITHIN
THEM.
WHAT'S YOUR READ IN ALL OF THIS?
>> WELL, IT'S ALL ABOUT WHO
KNEW.
AND LET'S LET THE FINGER
POINTING BEGIN.
LET'S TRACE IT BACK -- THIS IS A
FALSE STATEMENT.
THERE WERE WAY MORE THAN
NEWSPAPER CLIPPINGS AT
MAR-A-LAGO, WE KNOW THAT FOR A
FACT.
PAT PHILBIN, WHITE HOUSE LAWYER,
MADE THAT STATEMENT TO ARCHIVES.
HE'S SAYING I DIDN'T COME UP
WITH THAT.
I WAS TOLD BY MEADOWS.
MEADOWS IS SAYING, WELL, I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT FIRSTHAND,
SOMEBODY ELSE TOLD ME.
SO THE CHALLENGE HERE FOR
PROSECUTORS IS GOING TO BE TO
FOLLOW THIS CHAIN OF
COMMUNICATIONS ALL THE WAY DOWN.
MAYBE SOMEBODY'S ALREADY LYING
IN THOSE STATEMENTS THAT WE JUST
WENT THROUGH.
BUT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DIG
IN.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SEE IF
THEY CAN FLIP SOMEONE ON THE
INSIDE OR FIND DOCUMENTS.
SOMEBODY ALONG THE CHAIN HAD TO
KNOW THERE WERE MORE THAN
NEWSPAPER CLIPPINGS AND MADE
THAT FALSE STATEMENT.
WHOEVER KNOWINGLY MADE THE FALSE
STATEMENT COULD BE ON THE HOOK
FOR FALSE STATEMENTS CRIMES AND
FOR OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
>> YEAH.
WE SAW THE PICTURES FROM
MAR-A-LAGO, FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
I GUESS THAT ONE PICTURE THAT
SHOWED ALL THE DOCUMENTS WITH
BOLD LETTERS, "TOP SECRET," ON
THE DOCUMENT.
THAT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A PRESS
CLIPPING TO ME.
YOU KNOW --
>> IT'S YELLOW AND RED.
IT'S BRIGHT COLORS.
>> YEAH.
SO EASY YOU AND I COULD SPOT
THEM.
YOU KNOW, TRUMP WENT ON THE
"HUGH HEWITT" SHOW AND CLAIMED
THAT HE DECLASSIFIED THE
DOCUMENTS, EVEN AS HIS OWN
LAWYERS ARE AVOIDING MAKING THAT
ASSERTION.
LET'S LISTEN TO THAT.
>> MR. PATEL SAID HE WITNESSED
YOU GIVING VERBAL ORDERS TO
DECLASSIFY THE PAPERS THAT ENDED
UP AT MAR-A-LAGO.
DO YOU REMEMBER MAKING THOSE
ORDERS?
>> THAT'S CORRECT, AND NOT ONLY
THAT, I THINK IT WAS OTHER
PEOPLE ALSO WERE THERE.
BUT I HAVE THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO
DECLASSIFY, ABSOLUTE.
A PRESIDENT HAS THAT ABSOLUTE
RIGHT, AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
AREN'T CHALLENGING THAT ANYMORE.
>> CAN YOU GIVE US AN ABSOLUTE
FACT CHECK ON THIS?
>> THREE QUICK THINGS, JIM.
ONE, THE PRESIDENT DOES HAVE
VERY BROAD AUTHORITY TO
DECLASSIFY.
TWO, THERE IS ZERO EVIDENCE THAT
DONALD TRUMP DID EXERCISE THAT
AUTHORITY WHEN HE WAS PRESIDENT.
THREE, THERE IS QUITE A BIT OF
COUNTER EVIDENCE THAT HE NEVER
DID ACTUALLY DECLASSIFY